et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Aurélie trouver bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous député la France
insoumise de la seine-saint-yon va
évidemment parler de la réforme des
retraites puisque c'est un sujet que
vous suivez tout particulièrement à
l'Assemblée nationale pour votre groupe
Elizabeth borne qui a donc fait hier
dans le long exercice de pédagogie sur
sa réforme elle a juge indispensable et
elle a fait quelques ouvertures on va y
venir qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé hier
soir de cette interview d'Elizabeth
borne 9 sous le soleil alors même qu'on
a 80% des Français ça ne fait
qu'augmenter qui sont contre cette
réforme la totalité des syndicats de
salariés alors que nous avions 2
millions 800 000 personnes dans la rue
voilà selon selon les syndicats en tout
cas énormément de personnes dans la rue
et la colère monte parce que tous les
chiffres sont en augmentation dans les
manifestations on a aussi des centaines
d'établissements scolaires des facs qui
sont mobilisés donc les jeunes aussi
sont très mobilisés parce qu'ils voient
que ça va avoir des conséquences non
seulement sur leurs parents mais sur eux
justement parce que cette réforme va
produire du chômage et il le comprennent
bien donc malgré tout cela et bien elle
reste droite dans ses bottes et allons-y
gaiement dans cette réforme qui a des
conséquences je dirais je des
conséquences même Funès parce que l'on
sait que c'est alors moi je retiens
surtout ce chiffre 15000 personnes
supplémentaires qui ne verront pas à la
retraite qui seront mortes avant le
départ en retraite si on décale de deux
ans l'âge moyen de départ en retraite
alors elle elle dit pas qu'elle
évagulément en tout cas mais elle dit
que si on ne fait pas cette réforme le
système par répartition est menacé vous
n'entendez pas cet argument alors il est
faux d'ailleurs le président le
président du corps du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites lui-même dit
que les maîtris que les pardons les
dépenses sont maîtrisées d'ailleurs ça a
été ces 10 même dans le rapport du corps
il dit que les dépenses sont maîtrisées
mais que les retraités futurs n'auront
pas le même niveau de vie que les
retraités actuels alors ça veut dire
clairement une en fait ce que ce que ce
qu'il y a dans le rapport du corps c'est
ce qui ce qui est prévu c'est à peu près
sur le long terme sur 25 ans 10
milliards d'euros de déficit par an il
faut relativiser ces 10 milliards
d'euros et il faut regarder à quoi ça
correspond en fait ce sont des choix
politiques c'est-à-dire c'est c'est ce
que l'État accepte de mettre dans le pot
commun pour les retraités or aujourd'hui
et bien l'état il est prévu que l'État
réduise ça contribution à terme et ça
c'est tout à fait anormal alors même que
le nombre de retraités va augmenter par
rapport au nombre d'actifs nous ce que
nous demandons et ce que nous proposons
à travers tous nos amendements notamment
sur les six premiers articles et bien
c'est d'avoir d'autres solutions et il y
a plein d'autres solutions possibles en
fait le gouvernement a choisi la
solution la plus injuste qui soit c'est
à dire de reporter de deux ans l'âge de
départ légal à la retraite le nombre de
retraités va augmenter par rapport au
nombre d'actifs c'est à dire qu'il y
aura de moins en moins d'actifs en plus
de retraités est-ce que le système para
est tenable avec des pensions et bien ça
veut dire qu'il faut que l'État d'abord
compense ce qui est réduit à terme
puisqu'il va y avoir notamment moins de
fonctionnaires donc moins de
contributions des fonctionnements de
contribution de l'État donc dans le
système des retraites et ça ça n'est pas
normal il faut que l'État qu'on pense
alors comment il peut le compenser en
mettant un peu plus sur la table et ça
n'est rien 10 milliards d'euros quand on
voit les la richesses des ultra-riches
explosées Oxfam l'a mis en avant 2%
2% de taxes ou de de
ponction sur la fortune des 43
milliardaires de France ça permet de
compenser ces 10 milliards d'euros il y
a d'autres solutions par exemple les
dividendes du CAC 40 qui sont un niveau
historique à 80 milliards d'euros par an
il suffirait d'aller ponctionner 10% de
ces 80 milliards d'euros pour quasiment
compenser le déficit on pourrait aussi
trouver c'est pas 10 milliards d'euros
et après circuler il y a rien à voir
dans bien sûr
chaque année mais quand je vous parle de
mettre à contribution les dividendes du
CAC 40 et bien c'est chaque année qu'on
pourrait effectivement les mettre à
contribution pourquoi les revenus
financiers ne sont pas mis à
contribution pour cotiser au système
donc là aussi c'est une question et puis
je rappelle aussi que le gouvernement
vient de décider la suppression de ce
qu'on appelle la CVA la CVAE la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises qui va d'abord avant tout
vers les très grandes entreprises cette
CVAE il y en a pour 8 milliards d'euros
par an donc vous voyez ce sont des choix
politiques les choix politiques fait
depuis six ans parce qu'au gouvernement
et c'est ça qui ne passe pas auprès des
Français c'est que ce sont avant tout
des cadeaux fiscaux et des cadeaux aux
plus riches voilà et que à l'inverse et
bien on pénalise les retraités comme
d'ailleurs on a pénalisé les chômeurs
très récemment avec une assurance
chômage qui a diminué leurs indemnités
c'est toujours les mêmes qui payent le
gouvernement dit l'inverse et que si on
ne sauve pas le système par répartition
ce sont les Français les plus modestes
qui paieront parce que les Français les
plus ils ont les moyens de créer un
patrimoine de se créer une retraite
d'économiser durant leur vie pour se
payer leur retraite après vous
l'entendez cet argument mais alors ça
c'est d'abord totalement faux parce que
c'est très fort et extrêmement injuste
elle va elle va en fait s'en prendre au
plus précaire au plus à ceux qui d'abord
commence leur carrière le plus tôt
puisque c'est ceux qui ont commencé à 20
ans qui pouvaient espérer partir à 62
ans et qui finiront par partir à 64 donc
c'est eux qui se prennent deux enfers de
travail en plus à des âges où on est
épuisé par des travaux extrêmement
pénibles voilà c'est eux c'est aussi les
femmes c'est mon cas qui avait qui avait
pu avoir des des trimestres en plus et
qui pouvaient espérer partir à 62 et qui
se prendront deux enfers voilà ces gens
qui se prennent les deux enfers ce sont
les femmes qui ont des qui ont qui ont
eu des enfants qui bénéficient des
trimestres ce sont ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler le plus tôt et c'est tous
les Français par ailleurs il faut le
rappeler puisque même les carrières les
pénible où les aides soignants etc qui
avait qui ont de aussi des dispositifs
de départ un peu plus tôt voilà où les
pompiers par exemple ou les égoutiers de
Paris eux aussi se prendront les deux
enfers alors justement sur les carrières
longues Elizabeth borne hier soir a
promis un débat elle a dit oui je suis
ouverte un débat sur les carrières
longues est-ce que vous êtes satisfaite
et comment vous allez le mener sur les
carrières longues elle n'a rien proposé
de concret donc mettez-le sur la table
bon ça c'est la première chose
sur les 44 admis ils sont obligés
ouverts
ça ne veut rien dire ouvert au débat
d'abord ensuite je rappelle que tout ce
qu'il met en avant et de l'intox puisque
tout vise à détériorer à détériorer en
fait la condition actuelle des
travailleurs et de leur départ en
retraite toutes les situations mènent à
une détérioration en réalité donc y
compris sur les carrières longues c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui ce commencer à
travailler à 18 ans et bien vous avez
des dispositifs pour partir un peu plus
tôt et là ce sera empiré les seuls les
seuls qui peuvent espérer le statut Hugo
c'est ceux qui commencent à 16 ans ça
concernera dans 10 ans 300 personnes par
an donc franchement ils sont en train de
nous dire vous inquiétez pas il va pas y
avoir de détériorations pour 300
personnes par an quand tous les autres
il y a aussi par exemple les femmes sur
les pensions minimum il y a aussi
beaucoup de femmes aujourd'hui qui ne
touchent pas une pension minimum à 85%
du SMIC même en ayant une carrière
complète est-ce que vous reconnaissez
que pour ces personnes là par exemple la
situation va quand même s'améliorer
alors est-ce que vous parlez des 1200
euros minimum donc je vais parler des
1200 donc euro donc alors ça y est ils
en parlent déjà un peu moins parce
qu'ils ont compris quand même que
c'était vraiment gonflé donc ces fameux
1200 euros c'est pour une carrière
complète
50% des femmes n'ont pas de carrière
complète elles ont des carrières hachées
donc ça ne concerne déjà que 50% des
femmes ensuite cette loi en fait existe
depuis 2003 sauf qu'elle n'est pas mise
en oeuvre donc en fait une invente rien
c'est déjà dans la loi la gauche ne l'a
pas mis en oeuvre c'est déjà le met en
oeuvre alors excusez-moi mais quand vous
dites la gauche il y a beaucoup de
choses c'est ce qu'il y a d'abord nous
nous réclamons pas de l'héritage de des
50 François Hollande d'ailleurs nous
sommes foncièrement contre la réforme
Touraine et les 43 annuités au lieu des
42 à nuités qui qui vont subir avant
tous les femmes donc nous nous sommes
pour une réforme une retraite à 60 ans
et un rétrécit le fait d'avoir moins
d'annuité nécessaire pour pouvoir partir
en retraite à taux pleines ou c'est un
maintien à 62 ans dans un premier temps
et pour les 60 ans un peu plus tard ou
vous réclamez la retraite à 60 ans dès
maintenant nous réclamons la retraite à
60 ans comme elle est existée avant
c'est-à-dire que il y avait la retraite
à 60 ans il faut s'en souvenir et qu'en
fait nous avons eu depuis 20-30 ans une
période une toute une période de
régression des droits sociaux et que oui
maintenant nous nous nous pouvons avec
un pays qui est de plus en plus riche au
contraire avoir du progrès social et le
progrès social c'est quoi et bien c'est
de c'est de pouvoir gagner mieux alors
qu'on est chacun de plus en plus
productif dans notre travail et puis
chacun pouvoir travailler moins
longtemps dans sa vie dans l'année nous
sommes pour la 6e semaine de congés
payés et dans la semaine puisque nous
sommes pour les 35 heures effectives et
les abatsburn a fait une autre ouverture
hier soir sur l'index senior elle s'est
dit favorable à des sanctions contre les
entreprises qui ont de mauvaises
pratiques en matière d'emploi des
seniors vous les voteriez ces sanctions
alors là aussi moi je me dis bah tiens
c'est bizarre puisque on vient de faire
tout un débat en commission des affaires
sociales ils n'ont rien lâché pas un
seul amendement on en a proposé des
amendements des solutions constructives
rien n'a été lâché par la minorité
présidentielle rien donc et donc
d'ailleurs vous êtes satisfaite de ce
qu'a dit Elisabeth bornière soit
j'imagine mais ça veut dire quoi on
vient de faire les propositions
commissions des affaires sociales ils
ont tout rejeté donc il y a les discours
il y a les actes je veux dire il y a 24
heures il repoussait tout ce qu'on
proposait et alors on en a proposé des
façons de faire tout a été rejeté
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui pouvait un tout
petit peu contraindre les grandes
entreprises bon donc voilà donc
j'entends ce qu'elle dit mais ensuite et
bien il aurait fallu du coup accepter
nos amendements donc moi je veux bien
mais il y a les discours et les actes
voilà est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir
faire bouger l'exécutif il y aura 9
jours d'examens ça commence lundi à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
pensez pouvoir faire bouger l'exécutif
avant la fin de l'examen de sa thèse je
le dis pour nous ce qui ne va pas c'est
le cœur de la réforme c'est l'article 7
et le report de deux ans de l'âge de
départ légal à la retraite c'est ça que
refuse et que repousse tous les
syndicats de salariés il y a une unité
syndicale qui historique c'est ça que
repousse 80% des Français donc ils
peuvent déguiser parce que c'est ça tout
l'art de ce gouvernement c'est de nous
faire des intox de l'enfumage et de nous
dire mais alors ils nous sortent 10000
dispositifs qui soi-disant viendrait
compenser qui ne compense rien du tout
jusqu'à l'index des seniors qui est une
vaste blague qui est juste un index que
viendrait afficher les plus grands
entreprises sans aucune contrainte sur
elle sans aucun effet coercitif donc je
le dis le cœur de la réforme nous nous
voulons le mettre à bas c'est à dire ce
report de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite donc pour en
déguiser comme ils veulent le reste
c'est ça que nous voulons retirer on va
parler du débat à l'Assemblée justement
puisque plus de 20 000 amendements ont
été déposés dont 18 000 pour la nuque
est quasiment 13000 pour la seule LFI
pour deux semaines de débat neuf jours
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas clairement
dans l'obstruction parlementaire alors
d'abord l'obstruction parlementaire
c'est le gouvernement qu'il a produit
pourquoi parce que nous sommes sur un
texte essentiel pour la vie des Français
je dis bien que c'est pour la vie des
Français pas une histoire de tant de
budget etc c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
considère comme droit dans notre vie
est-ce qu'on a droit après une vie de
travail acharnée à s'épuiser etc c'est
ça ça concerne d'abord c'est c'est
travailleurs et c'est travailleuses
essentiels est-ce qu'on a le droit à une
retraite heureuse est-ce que le temps de
la retraite est aussi est-ce que c'est
pas aussi une richesse pour nous c'est à
dire le fait de s'occuper de nos
petits-enfants le fait de pouvoir
s'occuper d'associations de mairie et
puis le fait aussi de pouvoir se reposer
de toute cette de toute cette vie de
labeur voilà est-ce que vous dites on
assume une stratégie alors donc du coup
on a un gouvernement qui pour un texte
aussi essentiel pour nos vies qui nous
retirent deux ans de retraite
voilà on a un gouvernement qui nous dit
ça tiendra en hémicycle en quelques
jours voilà c'est à dire qu'en quelques
jours on est censé débattre de ce texte
là ça n'est pas possible de débattre
d'un tel texte en quelques jours alors
il nous faut un 40 de 300 déposer 75000
amendements ce qui aurait fait des mois
de débat est-ce que c'est pas aussi ça
qui a poussé le gouvernement à passer
par le 47 ans alors d'abord nous avons
dit qu'effectivement nous battre autant
que possible contre ce texte ensuite le
gouvernement aurait pu choisir un débat
parlementaire qui s'étale autant qu'il
faut pour pouvoir débattre correctement
de ce texte de fait qu'avant lui faire
le gouvernement court-circuiter les
mobilisations parce que ils savent très
bien que et bien les mobilisations ne
vont faire que monter donc il faut les
couper voilà et donc comment ils s'y
prennent et bien par un débat
parlementaire le plus court possible
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont trouvé ils
sont allés chercher au fin fond de la
Constitution ils ont des ils nous ont
pris le 47 ans c'est à dire un 49-3
déguisé à dire si au bout de 20 jours
pour jour après le la connaissance du
texte vous n'avez pas fini le l'examen
en Assemblée nationale et bien
automatiquement il sera voilà il sera
acté il va au Sénat mais enfin c'est
quoi cette démocratie c'est pas c'est
vraiment c'est étouffé la démocratie
parlementaire et après ils sont gonflés
quand même ils viennent nous dire que
c'est nous qui pourrissons les débats
mais c'est eux qui bloquent les débats
13000 amendements Aurélie trouver
comment vous voulez avoir un débat avec
13000 amendements c'est à dire que tous
les amendements ne sont pas des
amendements sur le fond du texte la
plupart de ces amendements sont ses
amendements sont sur le fond du texte
vous regarderez à chaque fois nous avons
fait des propositions échelonnées pour
espérer voilà pouvoir faire bouger ce
texte mais je le dis pareil nous nous
battrons contre le coeur du texte
c'est-à-dire ce fameux article 7 voilà
on va y venir mais juste je voudrais
vous faire réagir à un tweet de Marine
Le Pen hier lorsque vous avez déposé vos
je la cite en déposant des milliers
d'amendements la nuque va permettre au
gouvernement de faire passer la réforme
des retraites en première lecture sans
vote nous avions la possibilité de
rejeter ce texte mais leur stratégie
stupide d'obstruction va nous en
empêcher qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça alors déjà je répondrai que ça aurait
été bien qu'il soit là dans les débats
puisque dès qu'on a commencé à
commission des finances il y avait deux
députés sur 11 du rassemblement national
on les voyait pas je veux dire ils sont
pas dans les débats nous je veux dire en
commission des affaires sociales vous
savez quand on était on était entre 20
et 30 députés au lieu des enfin voilà on
est venu au maximum qu'on pouvait pour
participer au débat y compris au-delà
des dix commissaires puisqu'on y a le
droit pour pouvoir justement être voilà
être prêt et être affûté et pouvoir
participer pleinement voilà c'est notre
choix nous sommes à fond dans la
bataille parlementaire donc voilà je je
leur réponds ça nous nous sommes dans le
voilà nous nous faisons notre travail
parlementaire nous et c'est à dire que
nous avons déposé eux ils ont déposé
moins d'amendements que Renaissance quoi
enfin la blague donc oui pour d'abord il
nous fallait tous les amendements
nécessaires pour rejeter ce qui est
inacceptable et tous les amendements
nécessaires pour dessiner un
contre-projet parce que c'est vous voyez
bien que c'est énorme la question des
retraites sauf que du coup en commission
ça s'est interrompu sans que sans même
que l'article 7 qui est l'artiste de
l'âge n'est plus être pris de temps
parce que du coup est-ce que vous
craignez pas qu'il en soit de même en
séance et que cet article 7 que vous
voulez examiner mais vous n'ayez pas le
temps de les regarder pour un texte
aussi énorme on a commencé lundi à 9h30
à 20h à mercredi on nous a dit allez
ciao au revoir enfin je veux dire c'est
qui qui c'est qui bloque le départ
parlementaire et après on s'adresse à
nous mais parce que vous ne craignez pas
que si vous ne retirez pas une d'un
certain nombre de vos amendements
l'article 7 ne soit même pas examiné
mais c'est en fait on ne peut je suis
désolé on ne se mettra on n'acceptera
jamais on acceptera jamais ce blocage du
débat parlementaire c'est pas à nous de
retirer nos amendements parce qu'on a un
gouvernement qui est qui utilise un vous
êtes le 47 ans c'est à dire un 49-3 des
aiguisé et qui nous empêche d'avoir le
temps nécessaire c'est pas à nous c'est
au gouvernement de dire non pour un
texte aussi essentiel pour les Français
80% des Français si opposent il nous
faut un véritable débat donc la question
elle est pourquoi ce gouvernement a
choisi pourquoi a-t-il choisi ce qu'un
49 3 déguisé nous on a la réponse parce
qu'ils ont peur de la mobilisation dans
la rue ils ont raison d'ailleurs parce
que le 7 élo 11 février ce à quoi on
s'attend c'est énormément énormément de
monde dans la rue donc oui effectivement
aujourd'hui on a un gouver enfin je veux
dire on est quand même dans un moment
historique ou on a enfin c'est quand
même dans l'histoire d'avoir un
gouvernement une réforme aussi
impopulaire c'est quand même historique
et un gouvernement qui ne change rien
hier soir moi franchement j'ai regardé
Elisabeth je me suis dit quand même ils
vont un peu reculer rien donc voilà vous
voulez vous voulez un référendum sur
cette question de la réforme des
retraites du coup pourquoi ne pas voter
la motion référendaire du rassemblement
national lundi alors
nous contestons nous contestons ce qui
vient de se passer l'usage veut que ce
soit le groupe ou les députés qui les
premiers déposés la motion référenderz
ça se fait comme ça généralement et bien
l'usage veut que ce soit cette notions
référendaire qui soit votée d'abord
voilà c'est un peu fou le règlement de
l'Assemblée donc c'est ce qui se fait
c'est l'usage voilà la Conférence des
Présidents et donc la présidence ont
décidé quoi ont décidé en fait de
d'un tirage au sort ce qui amène à avoir
la motion référendaire du rassemblement
national je décrypte la minorité
présidentielle c'est choisi sa propre
opposition celle qui lui convient c'est
à dire cette opposition de pacotique et
le rassemblement national ils ont peur
et une autre motion référence exactement
parce qu'ils ont et on va faire en sorte
de que ce ne soit pas la motion
référendaire du rassemblement national
qui soit déposé en premier lieu ce n'est
pas déposer une nouvelle bien sûr mais
pourquoi ils ne veulent pas le
gouvernement parce qu'ils ont peur ils
ont peur que émotion référendaire soit
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont débrouillés
pour que ce soit celle du RN je mets
juste sur ce que vous allez faire vous
allez en déposer une nouvelle et donc
vous demandez quoi un nouveau tirage au
sort tout à fait donc ça sera ça voilà
bah on espère voilà c'est tout ce que
c'est pour l'instant alors d'aujourd'hui
c'est ça qu'on essaie d'avoir voilà
comme le veut l'usage par ailleurs
normalement l'usage aurait voulu que ce
soit nous c'est à dire si vous perdez
encore le tirage au sort qu'est-ce qui
se passe écoutez pour l'instant on est
là voilà et nous faisons que vous l'avez
déjà fait savoir et elle brune Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale que
vous alliez en déposer de nouvelles oui
donc là c'est c'est clair nous allons
déposer une nouvelle motion référendaire
et nous allons faire en sorte et bien
qu'il y ait voilà
cette cette procédure là et je le redis
il est scandaleux que ce ne soit pas
notre motion référendaire qui était
déposée en premier comme le veut l'usage
parlementaire mais si jamais
c'est la motion du rassemblement
national qui est soumise au vote si vous
ne la votez pas elle ne passera pas mais
de même que si le rassemblement national
ne vote pas la vôtre ne pourra pas
passer alors de toute façon nous n'en
sommes pas là nous aurons un débat vous
savez que on a on discute noir on a un
groupe parlementaire et donc de te tenir
je ne peux pas vous dire ensuite ce qui
se passera pour l'instant
national je ne peux rien vous dire
là-dessus nous nous attendons la
discussion en groupe parlementaire nous
avons 76 députés ce que je rappelle que
nous en avons gagné un dernier
législatives partielles donc on a un
député de plus contre la réforme des
retraites à 64 ans voilà donc voilà nous
nous en disque trons en gros
parlementaire mais pour l'heure on en
est pas là là on en est à contester et
voilà ce qui vient de se passer qui pour
nous est scandaleux voilà c'est à dire
que cette minorité présidentielle se
choisit une opposition de pacotique elle
rassemblement national
trouvé parce que vous avez beaucoup
parlé de la rue et de ce que vous
espérez des deux jours de mobilisation à
venir est-ce que vous dites aussi au
syndicat qu'il faut aller jusqu'à des
mesures dures c'est à dire des blocages
des grèves illimitées c'est pas à nous
veut dire ce que les syndicats doivent
faire par contre nous appuyons fortement
ce que ce que décide les syndicats de
salariés et en plus ils ont une unité
syndicale qui est historique nous
appuierons à fond de toutes nos forces
les 7 et les 11 février mais donc les
mobilisations mais je le dis aussi nous
avons notre propre campagne la campagne
de la nupesque et c'est voilà et nous
allons ce week-end je peux vous dire que
nous allons tout faire porte à porte
info point d'info retraite votation
citoyenne on va tout déployer au maximum
pour surtout que voilà tout le monde se
dit en fait c'est quoi la clé funéraire
là-dessus c'est vraiment de sortir de la
résignation parce que c'est ça qu'on a
compris c'est il y a 80% des Français
qui sont contre mais trop de Français
qui pensent que on va encore subir ça
donc là il faut qu'on passe voilà au
fait d'y croire et de se mobiliser merci
à vous d'avoir été notre invité et on
suivra bien évidemment les débats qui
débutent lundi dans les mythique de
l'Assemblée merci beaucoup on en parle
encore de cette réforme des trait tout
de suite dans le club